rolling hills near birchah village
hide a secret
an american army base
less than 40 kilometers from the ukraine
border
the 82nd airborne famous for its role in
the liberation of europe in world war ii
here now to answer
if war comes knocking on poland's door
so we were just at the armoire airfield
here in the forests near shemeshla sort
of tucked away behind all the trees
there was a heavy u.s military presence
there we asked to see if we could speak
to anybody we were given the contact
information for their public affairs
officers we spoke to them and they said
that currently that site is under a
media blackout and no one's really even
supposed to know that it's there yet
farms and tourist towns unaccustomed to
the sights and sounds of heightened
state security measures
[Music]
hundreds of extra officers more than
twice the normal number have been
stationed at polish border towns since
the russian invasion of neighboring
ukraine
responding to the refugee crisis but
also to respond to what the intelligence
community describes as russian
subversion and hybrid warfare we see
some kind of information campaign to
destabilize our society to sow a chaos
to sow
threats
or or even panic in
poland and among polish society but the
second group of threats are more serious
we see that this period of war against
ukraine can also lead russians
aggressors to attempt at for example
organize some kind of diverse and attack
in poland false frag operations against
poland
and
some kind of sabotage sabotage operation
lethal aid from western countries
transits through poland
ukraine's main ally in europe
intelligence officials say could also
become russia's next target
i'm not worried we have great services
which are protecting us i feel safe
calm words from a civilian leader in
military uniform
a clear sense of the current operating
environment in this city
poland is no stranger to russian
aggression and is doing more than most
to support ukraine
talk of permanent bases to protect
nato's eastern flank and remain a thorn
in russia's side
is something warsaw would likely welcome
cover
to keep helping a neighbor
with whom its fate is intertwined
zain basravi al-jazeera shemeshla
eastern poland